registro
salió
[música]
Bueno, ¿cómo puedes sentirte cómodo aquí?
sentir cuando cada día alguien
muere cuando somos amigos en diferentes
ciudades escriben que allí ha caído una bomba
alguien murió allí, un compañero fue asesinado allí
¿Cómo puedes sentirte?
Por supuesto que no es muy agradable, pero la vida
continúa y tenemos que continuar
[música]
Rick mi tu puedes y ya has volado a todos
ucranianos
Estoy en una noche tranquila, ustedes parejas a la victoria.
Allah esté contigo con espadín
Kirik tiene tres nietas más, tú tienes espadín.
Haré un sacrificio antes de ir al rey y quedarme.
Bueno, no podemos darnos abasto con la comida, volveremos a sonar una vez más.
soy todos ucranianos